so they're curious because you know when
I made this blog posts on your blog like
two months ago
the residents of language it isn't how I
feel at different languages so you live
in Paris go to the quality of a bar do
you ever speak to Italians in French
like does it feel different to you to
speak to the time you're French because
I know if I meet Americans in other
parts of the world and usually Americans
are pretty well lazy of languages first
of all and we don't have to speak to
each other but for some reason I am
speaking to another American is Spanish
or French it's really awkward
it's weird unless they speak it really
well but if I'm hearing them within a
very obvious American accent in Spanish
yo hablo espanol se I don't I speak to
them in Spanish so how is it for you
well normally you speak French with
other time friends when other people are
around so that everybody understands but
normally it feels very weird to speak
another way your specialty titles
sometimes have a bad habit of speaking
their own language even if other people
are around because it's our native
tongue and it's our way of communicating
for something I have a friend and do you
have found that wouldn't that I have
difficulty speaking in English even if
there are other people around this is
one thing I do remember I have another
journalism
my what happened is that and constantly
and will like to religion for the girls
and me and a friend of mine they were
constantly talking at the time and
making Clemens you know because it's for
us it's even if he could speak English
grass it's a you know it's it's normal
to speak in time to communicate it tell
me don't adapt sometimes I don't adapt
to a situation nor religion girls for
them it's pretty normal to speak English
to each other so that other people
understand it cuz it's like almost like
another language but Italians are
attached to their language so we love
our conference stuff and it's difficult
for us to speak another language you
know I tried it a couple of times with a
dear friend of mine speaks excellent
French but still it it's weird
so I tend to speak just a time with my
friends unless other people are around
and then we make an effort for a little
bit you hear a little bit a little bit
yes it's a little strange to speak
another language without every time so
less they speak even language very long
like English but it's still near like
times like identity you know it's with
my friends
speaking Italian Sam must it's a way to
communicate there's no other way around
even if he could speak I had University
there was a few of the Brits that we
would use different managers and it was
like I said you know that there was very
high level of language there's a friend
of mine who studied in the same degree
courses as man and she she and I would
speak in English French Italian
and then that's actually spoken in
gentlemen since I'm Dutch and it doesn't
actually feel weird with that because we
did it absolutely percent me from when
we first met ready so I never felt
strange I haven't gotten that many
English friends with whom I would speak
in different languages my wife for
example
I feel quite strange to be cancer in
English it's quite because we've our
whole relationship is based on on
Macedonian so there's natural thing for
us is to speak in Macedonian all the
time I mean even if we're back home in
the UK you know with friends and family
to be Macedonian
it's it's quite it's quite hard for us
to have a one-on-one you know you're at
a dinner table we would we would tend to
just even if everyone else is in
engaging in conversation and there's
just us we would just refer back to
Macedonia we would not just Karen in
English it would never happen
the only times that that would change
would be if we're in a situation where
it's a conversation between everyone and
we want to work commenting but we we
tend not to sort of have that
conversation together we can talk
through the pupil it's a bit weird and
my daughter speaking English obviously
I'd say things my wife speaks fluent
English and Josephine's in English she
will respond in Macedonian and I will
respond in English with it whichever
language are using the time and then but
then my wife and I'm just speaking
yesterday in fact when when my daughter
was very small because she heard me
speak only Macedonian at home with my
wife she used to translate from English
to Macedonian for me and so even if she
hid to hear me speaking to my mum in
English and then the numa dance us an
answer or she'd ask me something and
then the daughter would look at me and
she'd say daddy she said this and then
she'd say ultimately it was I don't know
why but it was and it was really hot and
she used me to continue English from my
mom and I was communicating English good
because usually I usually reluctant
interpreter I hated interpreting they
still do and here your daughter just
doesn't think she just does it naturally
and if she stop that has to shoot up
three sheets you realized that he did
speak English I mean you know it was it
was it was a bit weird but and I mean I
can kind of understand that because we
were living in the UK and okay she heard
in speaking English a lot but with her
on my own I spoke in French and then
with my wife in Macedonian so so with
her I didn't speak English while we were
you know mainly in the UK and maybe for
that reason I don't know but then from
the age of three she's got it shredded
really sorted in her head
okay these are the languages and this is
when I use them